[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
et ben qu'est ce que tu connais
bien
mais toi fils battus voire vraiment on
suit il faut ici dans trois quarts
d'heure au maximum je sais bien je
déjeune et n'est pas près la table n'est
pas mise en chauffe bien tu sais aussi à
quel point nous avons 228 oui parce que
ce que je sais le mieux et vous avez
carrément à la catastrophe c'est à ne
pas y penser dis moi qu'est ce que nous
avons comme déjeuner est pour le moment
rien comment rien absolument rien tu
évites ton cousin a déjeuné notre avenir
dépend entièrement de l'impression que
nous avons dû faire et toi rien habille
en retire comme des jeunes absolument
rien a besoin le mariage se passe sur le
fauteuil qui va te casser la gueule bon
bah c'est pas un post il est si mon
pauvre chérie je te le faire confirmer
et émile
baissière est ce que le boucher a porté
la viande non messieurs et l'épicier
est-ce qu'il est venu non monsieur et le
marlin livrer non messieurs merci madame
[Musique]
l'appel fois et demie en fait c'est bien
que salah gas j'aurais tant voulu avoir
un valet de chambre maintien des
téléphoner chez charvet chez blanc car
chez l'épicier j'avais téléphoné mais il
faut croire que ça ne suffit pas et tu
n'as pas du tout d'argent aujourd'hui
pas du tout en fait on avait déjà pas
beaucoup hier j'en aurai demain bons
coups mais demain je réponds parlement
de quoi payer notre déjeuner
d'aujourd'hui qui travaille
je pisse tonnes de 9 heures à 2 heures
du matin au bal wagram un homme comme
toi et que veux-tu ou suffit ce temps
julie pistons le seul ennui c'est que
j'en joue pas assez quand je pense que
t'as pas travail régulier ça mon amour
c'est un peu ta faute j'ai demandé à
fred une augmentation comme tu me
l'avais dit il m'a foutu à la porte
comme je te l'avais dit mais ils verront
y verront le jour en jour at-on
concertons où tu sais un concerto pour
cornet à piston et orchestre y'a pas
beaucoup d'amateurs c'est que meyer baer
a mis dix ans pour faire exécuter le
sien écoute je suis sûr que ça à cause
de ton scherzo de la possession est
carrément allé trop loin oui oui il est
peut-être un peu sensuelle un peu je te
possède et tu m'as procède t il ce poste
et puis n'en finissent pas et puis il ya
la favière oui je suis je suis en sus
elle s'est entendue je suis pas libertin
tu étudies mais la possession ça existe
non d'ailleurs nous allons faire une
chose
c'est parce que je voulais dû
repenser a déjà mené des temples et moi
je crève de faim oh ma pauvre jolie
d'habitude c'est moi que je mangerai
même quelque chose que je n'aimerais pas
ton nom tu mangeras du foie de veau par
exemple je te le givre faut absolument
que je fasse un effort je t'en supplie
combien doit-on la mer mancelle la
dernière fois que je les ai vus ils
parlaient de te casser son parapluie sur
la figure oui faut tuer c'est bien ce
que je crois c'est complètement fou
tutelle italien barbie n'est lit on doit
lui deux voies huit ou neuf cents fond
de moins qu'à elle mais pourquoi ça mais
y'a pas de raison à l'étranger à l'oeil
s'allume et qu'il va nous offrir le tai
shan et non il est belge et nous il est
italien alors je vais lui faire le coup
des poliakov si quand tu prend l'accent
russe oui c'est quand je prend l'accent
russe mais tu le prends comme un cochon
mais ne dit pas ça l'accent russe est
une de mes spécialités n'oublie pas que
je suis musicien pistons et sa tête pour
l'action russe
surtout avec un étal
oui peut-être bon alors il prend
pourquoi liakhov et puis poliakov habite
au dessus un chauffeur de taxi très
bonne réputation pas de d'être connu bon
je lui fais ma commande barbie déliement
voit le petit kobe qui ne me connaît pas
souligné pas je l'attend dans l'escalier
je le remercie avec l'accent russe en
lui disant que je passerai payer je
remonte ici faire la cuisine c'est pas
plus difficile que ça et si l'italien
vient lui même au lieu de t'envoyer sont
comme on tourne en rond frappe du coin
qu il va déranger pour un chauffard on
va essayer un qu'est ce que tu rival lui
pourquoi peut être tué mille parce que
moi je veux qu'elles ont ça en fait vers
eagle ont la taille porte c'est bien
moins qu elle rigole de temps à autre
elle se lit et tout à écoute mon petit
bonheur tu l'auras
allô allô allô la maison barbie nelly
ici pour un gars qu'on y croie l'accent
russe et battez-vous s'en est aperçu
ici fait deux hommes parlent au victoria
corps 14le de la bleue voir
alors celle balbine héliski mais laissez
moi parler au nom du petit père
ah bon alors chef marc minelli ce coffre
vous envoyer tout de suite par le petit
commis gros poulet aux spaghettis score
au 20 août ne fait pas rigoler mais
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient me fait
rigoler
ce qui peut mentionner c'est pas
croyable et juju commandes quand même le
déjeuner c'est pas la fête alors c'est
pas la peine voilà alors renforts ne
nous affolons abbas est pourtant la
seule chose à faire
il reste peut-être quelques pommes de
terre quelle pomme de terre ou après
pomme de terre même pas de pommes de
terre ainsi tu comptes et lui offrir des
pommes de terre oui pour le faire
patienter tout ce que nous pouvons lui
servir c'est un vin se doit alors
remarque il va peut-être pas fini on a
fait salle comble à la le comble au nom
sanyo familles sont brouillés depuis 20
ans lui et moi sommes vaguement
réconcilier mais si vaguement j'ai pas
eu l'occasion de te le présenter et puis
tu as il n'a jamais voulu me tutoyer il
doit bien se douter que si je les invite
à déjeuner c'est que j'ai une idée
derrière la tête dis moi comment est il
ton cousin olivier on peut alors que ce
qui sort cherchons plutôt ce qu'on va
lui donner à main ni à lens il taperait
réfléchissons à la semaine les chiffres
en bref il a choisi la regarde pas
réfléchi team trop tard nous vivions
quelle idée donner de la nourriture à
des gens qu'on a vite la conversation
devrait suffire nous les déjeuners est
ce que ça nous intéresse ça ne vous
intéresse pas a remarqué oui moi
aujourd'hui 6 tu sais qu'il ya des
femmes qui ferait des folies pour manger
qu'une fois par jour tu vois la chose
que tu as tu trouves que c'est le moment
de faire les guignols mais c'est
toujours le moment tu aurais dit je
pense que le petit gars à un autre quand
on a tu sais lorsque j'ai un oui
maintenant les mêmes je demande bien par
dont d'ailleurs talent mais ou à peu
près alors je trouve quand même qu'à
notre âge on pourrait prendre la vie un
peu plus sérieusement ou non madame tu
lui fais l'appel à cette petit lait sois
gentille va devoir à la cuisine si j'y
suis
voilà
de mon chéri tu te fais pas de deal en
ce moment alors ce moment précis ici en
ce moment je passe un très mauvais
moment seulement lors la plus noire n'a
quand même que 60 minutes est allé dans
attend un peu il va nous arriver quelque
chose des pâtes en t1 curable écoute moi
j'ai déjà cru qu'une douzaine de fois
que tout était perdu rien maintenant ne
m'empêchera d'espérer mais d'espérer
quoi d'espérer impossible de tous les
animaux l'homme est le seul qui espère
et et tu voudrais mauvaise avions il ya
un propos
c'est pas la peine de te demander si tu
a placé quelques uns de tes cendrier
artistique c'est pas la peine
pas un seul pas tout le monde trouve que
je suis une artiste belles pentes
colorier audacieux on n'achète rien un
bain restons là ils sont bien embêtés un
jeu
non non non non non non non non j'ai dit
oui là je souhaite prod chauffe
bon dieu de bon dieu ou encore le nez là
mon mouchoir mais je fais un mouchoir
quand j'ai un ennui dont il faut que je
me souvienne c'est nouveau ça mais que
veux-tu mois mais jean nuit j'ai
j'oublie tout de suite mais il y en a
tout de même dont il faut s'occuper sans
ça ils deviennent vite des emmerdements
et s'en serait à fin mai font croire qu
est ce que ça peut bien n'ai aucune idée
les loyers bien plus urgent que les
impôts je te dis que c'est urgent un
huissier ça m'étonnerait personne n'y
croit plus aux huissiers le téléphone
qu'on va nous couper mais un ennui je te
dis à l'électricité à l'eau et on ne
cherche que les oubliés va falloir les
passer tous en revue non non tu as
peut-être non c'est sa visite donc alors
on en manquait plus qu'à me faire penser
d'ailleurs
nous cherchons plus l'ennui c'est lui
c'est lui l'ennui celui il m'avait dit
je viendrai demain vers midi taux
réclamés mais 500 francs va le voilà
alors je disparais
bonjour
alors c'est
exact on peux pas t'en vouloir de ça
alors je viendrai chercher mes 500
enfants demain vers midi il faut pas sur
les photos tu veux te casser la gueule
au fait tu les as c'est quoi les 500
francs et 500 francs
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu crois que tu n'aies
zapata gagné jacques a dit cherry hill a
gagné qu'est ce qu'il a gagné je ne sais
pas au fait qu'est-ce que tu as gagné tu
pourrais peut-être de partout [ __ ] de
ma gueule en plus mais comment veux tu
que je m'en tire j'ai un ami charlot un
pti charmant automatiquement il me
paraît de 500 francs sans explication et
si vite que ça m'a étonné moi-même je le
rencontre vingt fois cent qu'il m'en
reparle si bien que j'avais presque
oublié et et pour le récompenser de tout
ce tacle moi ce matin je lui réponds que
je ne les ai pas eh ben c'est dur tu
sais je compatis d'un temps avait
vraiment besoin on a toujours besoin de
500 enfants et qu'il dit je sais bien
mais moi en ce moment j'ai même besoin
de ce que je te dois situe vous mettons
concerto
nada oyez pourtant formidable tu
n'aimeras se passa sur la possession la
cedh un osé oui dis donc ils se prennent
au moins du poids de suite là dedans
tout de même pas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils mèneraient pas ma fille à ce
moment là et le saut de puce ton quelle
merveille tu veux que je te joue
en a qu'ont merci mon vieux matin pour
déjeuner ad oui les jeunes et des jeunes
et ça va si mal
ça va pas très fort et isabelle mais tu
la connais courageuse et où elle rigole
pas un petit peu moins ce matin quelle
femme épatante c'est un grand bonheur
quand on parle de toi avec chaussin
c'est ce qu'on dit toujours il faut tout
de même qu'il ait quelque chose pour
être aimé de cette fable
ah oui vous dites ça oui
naturellement tu ne peux pas me prêter
encore 500 francs peut-être que cela m a
tant pis que veux tu qu'est ce que tu
dis je dis peut-être que si non mais
t'es fume seulement en échange il faut
que tu me rendes un ciré bah c'est bien
ce que disait t'es fou à qui veux tu que
je rende service en ce moment et tu en
bons termes avec ton cousin olivier en
bons termes avec moi je suis à temps
pour déjeuner non seulement j'ai même
pas une pomme de terre a lieu ce nom
alors attention au monde attention mais
c'est très grave ne fait pas l'idiot
tiens voilà tel 500 francs nous savons
seulement tu lui font un déjeuner de
derrière les fagots je ne demande pas
mieux avec du caviar ont besoin biggest
tpi j'ai 500 francs pour le déjeuner
c'est ce bon charles al alimi diva a les
couilles tu gagnes
tu vas aller chez garmin et elle a
raison faut que ce soit toi qui lis avec
moi je mets là mais pourquoi c'est trop
loin vous expliquer alors vous prenez
quelque chose de prévu tous les froids
salade et foie gras fromages et des
fruits exotiques exacte et fruits
exotiques et artois un panier dont
j'allais chez l'épicier voilà et
n'oublie pas de la fim de la fumée j'ai
jamais raison mais si vous aimez c'est
pas ben voilà il y avait les chaussons
mais sa fin ah bah non à ses poèmes il
faut que j'en rajoute encore voilà ouest
en barbie n'est tout de suite en sortant
à droite
si vous me rapportez une douzaines de
roses je vais épater personne mais c'est
pour cacher les trous qui sont dans le
mur permettez moi de vous offrir à 7 ans
aujourd'hui le fleuriste est enfin tu
veux pas aller dans les roues charmant
et non le service que tu veux me
demandez là c'est pas pour taper olivier
mais c'est à dire n'est ce pas alors on
vient y a rien de fait parce que moi
j'ai eu des preuves je ne veux pas taper
mais je vais être encore si c'est pas
pour l'état fait tout va très bien à
l'ego l'hydrogène routier
javelot la for
many
charest fermer ses portes
j'ai à vous nous serions bien bêtes de
nous en faire avec nous tout s'arrange
toujours dernier robe en effet mais si
tu calcules un peu en quinze ans
déjà 15 ans
en 15 ans a fait 5000 dernier moment
cinq mille fois que ça s'arrange 5000
petits miracles tu n'as pas peur que
nous épuise une autre chance peur que
dieu se fatiguent dieu se fatiguer de
nous écoute mon amour
est-ce qu'on a une absente roues
sans tous se retrouvent non mais celle
là est très convenable je ne peux pas te
fournir le superflu et le nécessaire en
plus mais je voudrais une fois dans
notre vie avoir trois jours d'avancé oui
mais ça je sais je suis
si tu avais épouse et mortimer
à banneux le calomnie phone joli garçon
est riche comme crésus j'étais assez
fier que tu mets préférés
on dira que que c'est un défaut de la
porcelaine et puis en plein travaux ont
coûté devant le trophée avec sa
cigarette
avec un petit peu de chance il nous fera
peut-être des excuses en priant que
c'est lui a fait a dit il et il n'est
pas bête charles dullin quoi tu dis ça
parce qu'il a prêté de l'argent non non
non non ça m'ennuierait plus tôt pour
lui alors ben alors il paraît que que
chaque fois qu'ils rencontrent chaussin
ils disent du bien de moi ont poussé
chant piano et 10 faut tout de même
qu'il ait quelque chose pour être comme
est une farce comme isabelle métayer à
quelque chose je ne parle pas de mon
talent de musicien ah non moi non plus
mais alors de quoi parles-tu alors mais
de toit du du personnage que tu aides de
ton égoïsme lui ne me dis pas que tu me
vois tels que je suis je crois que si
mais si tu pouvais en tome n'est pas du
tout tu es très bien nous sommes très
bien toi et moi nous sommes mais pas
pendant les embêtements restait à savoir
que nous donnerions dans le malheur dans
le malheur il n'est pas question de ça
on s'en fout de ça mais qu'est ce que tu
as ce matin je n'aime pas déjeuner j'ai
comme un pressentiment qu'il nous
apportera la catastrophe pourquoi j'ai
pas de pressentiment moi j'évite ainsi
les bêtises qu'on fait en s'efforçant de
lait juste et tu voudrais bien être la
femme que tu crois mais enfin mon chéri
mais qu'est ce qui se passe je voudrais
quelqu'un comme toi
égoïsmes n'ont insouciant gentil gay
mais tu es gay les femmes ne sont jamais
vraiment dit on les amuse tu m'amuses et
encore pas toujours c'est bête ce que tu
dis là c'est vrai quelques fois je
trouve trop gay on peut tomber est
tellement gentille devient fade au
[Musique]
toit tu es fatigué
je suis peut-être fatigué aujourd'hui
n'est pourtant pas pire que d'habitude
nos contraire et ben alors tu vois je me
demande qui peut donner cette conception
de la fiche à parce que j'ai une
conception de la vie loi mais oui tu
crois que la vie c'est une rigolade mais
c'est une rigolade chéri charlot qui
s'amène avec ses 500 france est une
rigolade je crois j'ai compris ces
pistes ont battu croître habiter quelque
chose dans le genre de
paris
et va tu crois que tu es gay oui je vois
pas pourquoi je serai la seule à faire
du souci on va [ __ ] cendrier sur la
trouve alors antilles c'est ton père
avait raison oui mais ça m'étonnerait
c'était un vieux jetons à viège temps
qu'ils avaient raison il disait
l'amour et ce devenir la plus noble
défaillance de l'intelligence du ton
attention
richard g
bon tu as tu as bien tous parfaits
tiens mon amour oh merci mon chéri ce
pigeon
tu perds mais c'est moi qui vous les
enfants ah oui c'est lui qui depuis 7
mois vous auriez dû prendre un seul à
bord ne pouvait s'imaginer qu'on a
acheté ces petits pour lui avant tout
arrêter un peu fanée j'aurais pensé que
nous en avions l'habitude notre mandat
et nous en avons d'habitude tient pour
la pentecôte on en avait erré aussi de
la moutarde et des corniches au mercy la
moutarde et écrit-il en 15 ans nous
n'avons jamais manqué de moutarde aa
puis on fait et qu'est ce que tu voulais
que je demande pour toi olivier ah oui
tu sais que les garages et d'abord
newbie sont à lui les garages et tous
paliers ou comme tu dis aussi voyez rue
du poteau je ne suis que son gérant je
le savais pas alors figure toi que
robillard va s'installer à limoges alors
je voudrais que tous cousins me donne sa
place à la fin du mois parce que tu
comprends le boulevard gouvion saint cyr
c'est quand même autre chose que la rue
du poteau
je pense bien qu'ayant take that chick
trice club dans deux ans moi je pourrais
m'installer à lima et bah bravo graillot
me fixais rendez vous après demain il
suffirait que tu lui glisse habilement
un box à la mule charlot est ce que vous
voyez encore les trous qui sont dans le
mur et drogué thomas derrière ça il y
avait des trous dans le mur vous les
voyez encore non le apple iphone et la
suie lalanne on a vu un afflux merci
seigneur maligne et moi
c'est isabelle quand je mets des villes
à la cuisine et je peux me rendre utile
[Musique]
julienc a ras le bol chaleur car a pris
mon dieu sait plus distinguer
la classe quoi
360 francs à m'appeler monsieur et bien
tu diras que tu as oublié de me la
rendre avant vous les aimez bien et oui
je sais bien s'en fout l'état ne va
surtout pas tu imaginer une chose
pareille ils s'aiment tu comprends alors
nécessairement il ne ressemble pas aux
autres maman dis qu'ils sont fous c'est
pour ça qu'elle m'a envoyé à sa place
elle veut plus travailler ici seulement
paraît que ça m'apprendra la vie mais
alors cette amère qui est folle si tu
apprends la vie ici tu es foutu
[Musique]
gemini la machine à laver
ça évidemment
tu sois plus utile à la cuisine vous
voyez mes fils et comme dessert qu'est
ce qu'on a
[Musique]
ça y est j'ai terminé il ya plus de ce
legs
s'est pas fait
mais ne parlons plus de ça merci pour
tout mon vieux char parlons plus de sale
[ __ ] tu veux dire plus jamais alors je
veux dire ma part plus ce matin la
mairie mais plus jamais c'était trop ce
genre nous ce genre de conversation et
ça ça tombe bien moi aussi mais que la
foudre m'écrase simon premier argent
n'est pas pour toi
n'en sais rien c'est bien ce sont les
travaux à côté
accueilli par un tu as cru que la foudre
soit tu peux toi pas dit dans mes toi ma
place ben hassan a dit je ferai quand
même tout ce que je pourrai alors tu
penses à nos garages ses jurés et au
fond tu es et pato et oui pour garder un
ami comme toi il faut tout de même que
j'ai quelque chose à l'écart au charango
au revoir isabelle
a décidément je vous aime bien
[Musique]
cal chic divin ce charlot est d'accord
sinon comment va devenir en 2000 francs
réseau il a dit que ça ne presse pas
j'avoue que je compte un peu sur olivier
tient auguste compte sur moi vous
n'allez pas écouté oh que si je suis
très curieux ma chère je sais alors il
est joli carton sur ye yang il est bien
il est mieux que ça et vous ne vouliez
pas que j'écoute assez merveilleux
merci auguste beaucoup mieux que moi et
qui m'a pas dit qu'il était très
intelligent ouais je ne sais plus où m
il n'avait pas vu les facteurs qui m'a
dit un jour je sais pas si j'étais visé
c'est toujours par hasard qu'on
accomplit son destin autres eh bien oui
ce n'est pas mal dimanche le président
doit plus fin avec lui au ghsr efforts
je lui dirai tout carrément c'est
tellement mieux surtout qu'il se plaît
aussi c'est trop salée tour il a
toujours l'air me fous de ma gueule
à thé jourdan
et à vous ma chère elle est exquise
simplement des cieux sublime des cheveux
super à sourire désarmant et les
antilles est bas les formats courts le
sensationnel je suis gêné et elle est
elle pas pas beaucoup ne peuvent pas
savoir
je croyais que ça mais il semble que non
pas ce qui est certain c'est qu'à lui
pardonne tout et je te prie de croire
qu'elle a du travail
un vrai [ __ ] oui
il est dedans pas un vous allez laisser
par lino c'est très intéressant il
suffit juste pas content avec et je
comprends pas bien
réfléchi seul il est tellement compliqué
il la tortue mais il est peut-être qu'en
pensez vous je n'ai pas envie de penser
à ça elle était peut-être ce nomme pas
lui étais sûr qu elle a peut-être voulu
être reçus à lui il a sûrement voulu de
plus est pauvre la menace vient à temps
parce que tu es là pour johnny tu peux
être sûr qui s'est surtout intéressée à
son argent or
mais se dire que si je te dis pas qu'on
traîne si tu dis oh pourquoi veux tu que
je te dis oh
alors tu vois toi aussi
aussi parce que les bois à ce qu'on dit
vous c'est de terre
t'as pas vu ce que j'ai acheté comme vin
rouge
elle voit tout ce qu'on lui donne je
suis si c'était partout parce qu'elle
essayait l'oublier mais en ce moment la
pauvre elle doit essayer d'oublier qu'il
est avec un mannequin
qu'elle gaffeur vous ne le saviez pas
d'ipad en hausse de 4 cents au menu pas
de toit qui rend ce n'est pas tout il a
bien failli y aller en prison et que la
politique non on avait même chassé de
son cercle
j'y suis rentré lily est rentrée en tant
que donneur ça pousse ça c'est bien vrai
enfin pour nous résumer une vraie petite
vache chèvre auguste sur cole se servait
de son argent pour faire le bien si nous
emmener un peu à nous ils comptent
patrons n'ont en effet paraît qu'il est
très dur à la détente match c'est égal
la gueule qu'il ferait si nous entendez
je vous entends
qu'est ce que tu dis qu'est ce qu'il dit
jeudi je vous entends
ah oui c'était bien de moi que vous
parliez
ça dépend depuis quand es-tu là je suis
arrivé à la vraie petite vache à là haut
on parlait déjà plus de toit
vraiment vous ne soit pas bête bon on
parler de quelqu'un de très dur à la
détente tu penses bien que c'était pas
de toi toi tu tu n'es pas durant la
détente et de qui parlez-vous alors ne
te connais pas chaussin chaussade chaud
soleil généreux comme le soleil du midi
emma pas avec moi
c'est parce que le le cousin et la
biquette
ne ne t'inquiète pas il vient d'arriver
tout va très bien et il est entré au
moment où on parlait d'eux de la petite
vache minuit et olivier a même cru un
instant qu'il s'agissait de lui ne me
crois tu que c'est drôle alors j'ai dû
lui expliquer qu'on parlait de chaussin
bah oui tu connais et chaud samedi mais
le connais très bien bon alors tu te
dépêches mais vous l'excusons bien s'il
me dit pas bonjour aux arguties
suis enchanté de vous revoir
non mais oui mais oui comment à à
auguste tailhades à augusta yann moix
pas connaître à pas connaître aux noms
ici fedom pavlovitch poliakov
commencez-vous poliakov
c'est vous passer les nuits poliakov oui
oui d'accord et pas alors da da da da et
puis nitcheu vaut un oui mais c'est
quelqu'un qui se trompe est le numéro un
russe ne voyez pas la manette ça enfants
labadot merci tout de même pour le
compliment j'ai bêtement rentrer la
voiture dans un camion nous avons dû
prendre un taxi et le chauffeur n'a pas
de monnaie
voyons voir émile
mais c'est c'est eh bein voyons et tout
à l'heure chez nicolas est ce qu'on vous
a rendu l'âme au noir voulaient pas
j'étais m'engueuler comme l'a rendu
excusez là
et est-ce qu'on vous a rendu ce que vous
avez rendu au monsieur non bâti rudement
intelligent que tu sais
j'ai vraiment des amis et vatan bon
alors c'est pas tout ça bon alors une
ligne tu vas descendre si vous le
permettez mon cousin gnl m'amène non
mais laissez nous on ne connaissait pas
sa fille elle n'en fait qu'à sa tête
merci merci nous
elle a vraiment des yeux
sublime
qui se fit
mais pourquoi dis tout ça parce que je
passe vous ne trouvez pas qu'elle a des
yeux subli six ans bon je me disais
aussi mais ça y est bien le seul pas sur
le fauteuil tu vas te casser la gueule
merci pourquoi les prévenus qui fit à
travailler avec miss in game à auch bat
reste il est votre came here is gone
camériste
c'est celui que les drames mais ça aussi
tiens tu seras là oui
avis assez haut c'est un défaut de la
porcelaine je vois je vois
merci au fait qu'est ce que c'est que ce
titre que j'ai rencontré tout à l'heure
dans l'escalier quand il m'a aperçu il a
détourné la tête ah oui pourquoi veux-tu
vite face à je ne sais pas mais j'ai
l'impression je le connais un haut nos
dix mois gégé a parlé nous pourrions
profiter de ce que les femmes ne sont
pas là vous cacher des choses à votre
femme moi ça ne lui est pas monté une
fois en quinze ans aux mêmes bancs
mission pas une fois au voilà
encore une histoire d'amour gbagbo
probablement afin d y en a est la
question n'est pas là un référé mais
mon cher olivier
quel ennui de ne pas avoir de chance je
ne sais pas j'en ai
au nord que tu me jeter sur pas réussir
trop vite plus on ne sait plus que faire
après enfin évidemment si on regarde les
choses en face
il faut avouer que le piston ne nourrit
plus son homme mais pourquoi ne pas
accepter les propositions que vous en
faite braquer d'abord et et hugo n'est
ensuite
avec l'argent que j'ai refusé j'ai
acheté un peu de liberté c'est joli
très belle réponse de cigales mais
quelqu'un de moins polique mois serait
sans doute en droit de vous dire eh bien
dansez maintenant
bon je sais votre femme
c'est isabelle
alors la manche et auguste bravo sûr
merci quels cieux oui mais qu'elle
sourit oui quelle silhouette
oui
oui quel mystère j'aime déjà moins ça
aille pourquoi le mystère n'est pas une
qualité pour le mari mais comme hors du
coup j'ai tu comprends pas très bien
enfin comment tu l'osés vous cacher
pendant 15 ans mais c'est moi je me suis
cachée pour être heureux naturellement
avec auguste alors là bravo buste encore
une fois donc vous avez très étudié oui
j'en ai eu nous nous étions à la faire
dévier moi je reviens dans cinq minutes
non
comment non monde son histoire le
s'annonce déjà pas comme quelque chose
de très amusant honnêtement
non c'est pas une histoire dourdan alors
venez pas me punir voit aussi nous
allons vous punir dont je vous ai appris
à y rester
puisque vous insistez si gentiment ge
oh je vous écoute
bon alors je serais bref
il faudrait que tu me près de 3 millions
enfin 30 mille francs
c'est entendu
comment s'est entendu tu me demande même
pas pourquoi pourquoi
il ya un petit bar salon de thé très
gentil très coquet à auteuil
tu m'écoutes pas nos six titres coquet à
auteuil avec trois millions ils nous
prendrait pour associer dont je jouerai
du cloud tout d'abord et puis après
quand ça marche mais je pouvais
reprendre le piston avec un petit
orchestre et écoutez écoutez vous ne
vous n'allez pas vous raconter votre vie
je vous dis que c'est entendu
je te remercie au jeu vous fait le
chèque tout de suite
si tu veux quelle est la date elle est à
retenir le
bluesman angers j'élève de me répéter
mais alors là franchement auguste encore
une fois bravo
vous êtes sûr que nous pouvons accepter
sur
augusto si auguste surtout alors je vous
remercie moi aussi eh bien voilà
maintenant que les relations soient
rétablies j'espère que nous avons nous
voir tout le temps
vite pas du tout nous allons avoir
beaucoup de travail
parce que vous travaillez aussi
naturellement aux usa c'était sa mort
mais vous viendrez nous voir pour bah
oui et puis si vous les amenez vos amis
nous pourrons vous rembourser à la fin
de l'année non non non pas de la cvo la
paix relancées au contraire ça nous vous
sommes très reconnaissants de la chance
que vous offrez mais nous devons la
mérite et non écoutés demandez lui de ne
plus parler de ça invite la raison on
parle du sort qu'en décembre
c'est bizarre vous savez je vous montre
pourtant beaucoup de sympathie et on
dirait que vous avez peur de moi moi je
suis pourtant pas le diable tant pis ça
m'aurait intéressé
je ne suis pas sympathique
trait
le plus subtil mensonges des femmes
c'est peut-être de mentir mal
j'aime en a assez pour me faire savoir
que je ne suis pas sabbatique 10 dont
olivier tu voudrais pas me dire un mot
de temps en temps
je ne vous suis pas sympathique mais si
mais si pascal a causé une bonne fête à
moins ils viennent nous prêter 30 mille
francs chez sa fille ne s'intéresse pas
à ces détails sauf pour vous féliciter
aujourd'hui j'ai ma cousine vous êtes
bien joli c'est vous qui me dit ce et
encore elle n'est pas à son mieux il
faut la voir quand elle n'a pas les yeux
rouges il paraît oui c'est une poussière
dans l'oeil probablement oh non j'ai
peur qu'aujourd'hui ce soit leur couleur
naturelle je dors dit quelque chose qui
vous ait peiné vous êtes probablement la
seule personne qui ne puisse pas faire
de peine voilà un déjeuner qui s'annonce
bien j'ai une femme parfaite qui
comprend tous qui excuse tout
malheureusement je ne la mérite pas
soyez doux naturels on pourra peut-être
se mettre à table un excellent avec ma
cousine
je vous imprimez
voulez vous vous placez à ma droite oui
avec plaisir
on attends attends tu crois que tu sens
que tu feras mieux si tu vas même
pardon monsieur liquide mettra la main
sur le butin briscard il est normal que
ce soit à quai le soleil dans l'oeuf le
soleil ne me gêne pas l'habitude de vous
regarder je lis cousine
m émile
alors aulas va
est-ce que je hais ce que je pourrais
avoir un peu d'alcool s'il vous plaît
oui mais certainement figurez vous que
cette pauvre sophie appris ce matin les
petites blagues que je faisais avec un
charmant mannequin olg est toute petite
blague
nuque émile apporte la fine quoi
la fille avec le mark et drôle d'idée
elle est impeccable
impayable sa chaîne logistique
excusez moi mais il faut il faut tout
faire par soi même si
vous êtes charmante où les charmants
vous êtes des phénomènes et finalement
les statistiques démontrent que l'amour
partagé et côté cette année à trois et
demi pour cent contre 31% en 1964 17 et
demi pour cent de perte et c'est normal
d'ailleurs la mer se retire tous les ans
doit mettre 22
ha oui vous faites donc partie des trois
demi pour ça
et
et vous vivez ici depuis quinze ans vous
voyez ici c'est ce tour de force nous
avons tout de même trois pièces au tout
de même merci il faut que je vous invite
à gros rouge ils appellent ça le château
ce n'est pas un château mais enfin il y
a de la place
vous verrez qu'on peut tous mais vivre
ailleurs que rue de l'abreuvoir à
l'écouté pleins je ne vous demanderai
pas d'y vivre auguste ne se plairait pas
il avait non plus je ne suis pas
tellement sûr je connais ma femme
connaître les femmes c'est savoir qu'on
les connaît pas non moi je te dis là les
formule étonnante aux jambes même une
femme d'une seule pièce comme sophie je
ne suis pas sûr de la connaître j'espère
que nous je connais isabelle ne connaît
que fera d'elle un château nous avons
été les qu'une seule fois en vacances à
vichy où tu n'as pas raconter cette
histoire si si et à l'art à l'hôtel on
nous a montré une chambre à deux lits et
il avait la demande et dans lequel
couche on nous
avait dit ça
ne fait pas comprendre il n'a jamais les
personnes qui louent même ma chère qui
aimait il est super vous peut-être enfin
si ce veinard d'auguste ne ça n'était
pas chargée
plaisante pas du tout et vous renvoyer à
une femme
vous mentez à pied six états il n'a pas
aimé ça pour retrouver cette man sahara
pour vous asseoir dans ce fauteuil
vermoulu pour manger danser si c'est
l'un des fonds de la porcelaine
et sur ses nappes brûlés par des
cigarettes délire des murs dont nous
gâchent en tant bien que mal les trous
avec des fleurs derrière des fenêtres
qui donnent du racime thiel mais il n'y
a pas foule il fait tellement que les
unions c'est stupide excusez moi je vous
demande un nom ne vous excusez pas votre
action est des plus intéressantes mais
alors je me demande si j'ai bien fait de
vous prêter cet argent
oui si c'est rigolo seul et auguste je
suis extrêmement sérieux dans votre
petit bar vous allez voir d'autres gens
et connaître une autre vie et je me
demande si vous n'avez pas me sentir
encore plus pauvres ne lui répondait pas
une règle d'or mais je
ne parlais que dans votre intérêt
émile romain auguste c'est un véritable
grillon du foyer il est charmant vous
avez bien dit ça
vous dit tout va bien d'ailleurs même
les choses les plus avancées
je sais que ce sont là d'innocents de
plaisanterie ce qu'ils voulaient fait
devant votre femme ou moi je ne gêne pas
mais vous ne devriez pas continuer de
vous moquer de moi plus longtemps je me
moque mois puisque vous le faites il est
certainement très normal de regarder une
femme dans les yeux en cherchant son
pied sous la table et pas tellement
normal ne glisse n'a pas l'habitude il
va se fâcher auguste de se fâcher
[Rires]
tu viens de la famille toi tu as tu as
le bon mourir des taillades
je ne trouve pas
je dois me tromper la caisse qui ne
faisait rien et c'est le mari vient sur
nar nous avons un petit retard web
landaise qui me faisait rire et oui oui
tu ris pas souvent là fallait que ce
soit drôle jugés 'sans isabelle disait
que vous allez vous fâcher
habitude ises à hawaï c'est drôle et
isabelle me connaît bien si elle le dit
c'est que je vais faire je vous dois
voir ça il a été sevré même probablement
si je ne fais pas ton cousin veut se
rendre intéressant nous nous
plaisantions il plaisanté
toi
tu as dû manquer de tact de tact ont
volontairement ne te fâche pas
volontairement
seulement tu vas comprendre tout de
suite il faut pas en manquer si tu veux
que je garde ton chèque je comprends
donc non en temps normal mais je suis
pas du tout susceptible mais j'ai
compris tant mieux j'ai compris mais je
ne suis pas convaincu vous faites
semblant d'être énergique je fais
semblant d'être épaté ce qui fait
semblant de vous croire
isabelle fait semblant d'être révolté
que je lui fasse du pied sous la table
quoi mais nous savons tous très bien que
vous ne vous fâche réparé lui son chèque
le soyez pas net sa fille a raison ne
soyez pas bête plus un geste et jolie
plus en le regrette et celui là serait
très jolie rang lui son chèque oui mes
succès
alors voila
merci on se fout de ton chèque n'ont
jamais eu d'argent ça fera que trois
millions de plus que nous n'aurons que
vous n'aurez plus qu'à vous laisse à vos
yeux ce n'est pas la même chose vous
verrez
j'avais tout combiné
surtout que nous obligerait à teyran 1
10 de dons mais moi qui vous croyez
stupide j'aurais bien voulu site annonce
une nouvelle petite vache quand vous
disiez
entendu tout notre conversation et oui
c'est mon excuse sophie vous avez
entendu aussi j'en ai entendu bien de
votre comme dit olivier je suis blindé
mais il sera puni vous serez punis
à
taipei non il ya eu peur du bruit il a
cru qu'on allait plus dire
à 30 ans comment trop tard nous allons
être obligés de prendre congé vous venez
sa fille une seconde
sa fille je vais avoir l'air mufle mais
maintenant j'ai pu les moyens de me
permettre un autre joli geste pourriez
pas me rendre la monnaie l'abonné du
taxi je vous demande pardon voilà et ils
vous dois encore 37 francs
je compte sur ton mandat
télégraphique si possible des graphiques
essayer de ne pas m'en vouloir je suis
sa femme malgré tout isabelle je suis
désolé que vous soyez là lui là la
victime de cette lutte fratricide mais
il est bien entendu que je reste votre
ami dévoué et que vous l'aurez cage est
acheminée au visage j'ai pas de salive
j'en ai moi
fous l'camp
quant à vous foule quand je te casse la
gueule
je pense à celles que vous ferez dans
une heure olivier je vous attends
olivier à très bientôt il amer à très
bientôt
quand il va passer sous la fenêtre lui
bien qu'un soit est
le [ __ ] le salon le salon ne
manquait plus que ça
têtu place biquette je ne sais pas pour
les trois millions dix
[Applaudissements]
tellement bas dans mon chéri
et
je te demande pardon mon chéri
auguste
mais avec à
allo
non
non je vous répète que non et vous
pourrez dire à monsieur olivier que je
quitte paris
qu'est-ce qu'il ya peu d'un exode moi
non montée si si tu t'entraînes dit la
maison il suffit de manger dit à maman
monsieur et madame ont sûrement besoin
de moi il faut que j'y aille tu t'es
trompé je suis sûr que vous avez besoin
de moi je me sens même si physiquement
je ne croyais pas bh stature pu éprouver
n'avons absolument pas besoin de toi
messieurs non plus non monsieur non plus
je lui demande est inutile vie n'est pas
rentré pas rentrer mais les plus de huit
heures bah oui
vous avez pleuré moi vous savez pas vous
ai pleuré qu'est ce que tu m'as imaginer
la gfp ferme la fenêtre vous ça fait
froid on étouffe
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se
passe
c'est depuis que le salon et demi l'udu
quoi c'est un salon monsieur dit tout le
temps c'est pas une raison pour le
répéter depuis ce déjeuner mais ce n'est
plus le même
toi tu trouves que c'est monsieur
forcément ça l énerve tout ces paquets
toutes ces corbeilles que l'on autre
plus en voix
j'aurais jamais cru qu'un jour je
pourrai détester les fleurs moi non plus
mais qu'est ce qu'ils espèrent c'est à
midi comme tu es gentille mon petit mais
je te comprends pas très bien voyons
enfin tu dîner tranquillement chez toi
et est subitement quoi je pensais à vous
deux comme d'habitude tu penses à nous
d'habitude tout le temps qu'est ce que
vous voulez maintenant est une bonne
grosse me viendrait pas à l'idée de
penser à elle
et là subitement j'ai eu comme à pass
mon coeur terrible il a fallu que je
vienne parce que nous avions besoin de
toi oui messieurs surtout tu craignais
un accident nous menons c'était pas dans
gens-là alors quoi dit moi vite chez
facetté c'était terrible le voilà enfin
madame isabelle
on se mirent à monsieur glisse à 3
oh
non
alors on peut dire que tu est cernée par
les fleurs
on voit plus les trous dans le mur faut
être juste
pourquoi entre tissi tard seulement moi
je vais avoir l'air idiot avec montbrun
tu perds mes chéris un petit brin de
muguet c'est un porte bonheur tu en
auras besoin pourquoi tu dis ça pourquoi
dis-tu savez je dis ça parce que je te
jure que tu veux en avoir besoin je te
le jure sur la tête de thomert tiens on
va bien rigoler taveroff soit la seule à
rigoler pour village comprend pas un mot
est ce que tu me dis tu me trouve
bizarre 20 ch est pas encore là mais je
suis sûr que tu me trouve bizarre un peu
oui eh ben je vais t'expliquer pourquoi
c'est parce que je suis bizarre
et alors maintenant devant moi pourquoi
je suis vise pourquoi
et mais je peux pas te le dis je peux
pas encore de le dire il faut d'abord
que je te prépares
je suis calme aussi un
non mais tu me trouves pas calme
et ben c'est idiot parce que je devrai
page je suis ton calme mais ça ça
m'inquiète
pas dit dans quel état tu est dans un
état complet d'ébriété tiens tiens on
dirait que ça te fait plaisir
d'ici là merci oui oui tu me fais pas de
reproche tu me demande pas pourquoi je
me suis mis dans cet état si je te
demandes pourquoi es tu vas je peux pas
te le dire non plus tout ça se tient je
suis
suisse ou parce que je suis bizarre tu
as des ennuis vous mais je vais en avoir
ah oui et tu m'écoutes pas non au bout
mais ceux qui le font je regrette mon
chéri en parlera demain si tu veux un
nom mais demain il sera trop tard quand
un mec
tu veux pas pleurer pour ça pleurait
pourquoi c'est le punch du tabac de la
galette ils avaient un compte
ils en ont plus
est-ce que nous ne pourrions pas partir
comment partir ou c&a partie n'importe
où chez son frère à la campagne ça ne
tombons pas partir moi j'aurais l'air
non nous ne pouvons pas l'un fait le
voyage n'est pas cher nous ne pouvons
pas je te dis qu'ils conviendraient pas
nous chercher là bas au contraire ce
sera leur première idée et à qui
tu veux pas me donner mes chaussons s'il
te plaît que c'est probablement la
dernière fois que je l'aimais qu'est ce
que tu dis avant d'en faire tu vas
continuer à parler par énigmes va
continuer à parler par et du oui oui je
vais continuer à parler part émis
pendant un petit bout de temps que je
passe moi la fine je crois qu'il y en a
là avant qu'ils trouvent pas assez sous
comme ça jamais assez tout ce que j'ai
fait n'est rien le plus difficile c'est
te le dis parce que tu as fait quelque
chose on nous écoute mon amour me pose
pas de questions j'ai déjà bien du mal à
comprendre ce que ce que je dis surtout
il faut pas que ce soit trop clair je
suis pas trop clair au moins aux anneaux
ah bah tant mieux
le pata soir
étant donné ce que j'ai à dire tu ferais
peut-être mieux ta soir
puis tiens voilà où elle affine sous ton
nez oui mais voilà où est mon nez
vas me dire si c'est pas le moment de
faire le guignol d'ailleurs j'ai pas
rigoler de l'après midi c'est tout dire
c'est pas possible ça oui tu me diras la
vie n'est pas un amusement 1
mais moi je te répondrais la vie
ou
c'est pas grand chose
comment tu dises at oui oui je dis ça
moi j'irais même plus loin y'a qu'une
chose certaine dans la vie
c'est qu'on la perd
elle n'a jamais été si courte d'ailleurs
remarque courte est bonne c'est déjà pas
si mal mais enfin il faut reconnaître
qu'elle n'a jamais été si court alors tu
me diras que le vrai courage c'est de
vivre du nab a tort mais moi je te
répondrais
faut pouvoir
au pouvoir moi je vais te dire une chose
ce que ça lui dans la mort
selim mortalité allant et je suis quand
même logique hein parce qu'enfin à non
non là je vais tout de même un peu trop
loin oui je crois aussi bien d'ailleurs
à propos d'olivier la question d'olivier
et si
la vie courte et bonne
course surtout
c'est lui
qu'est ce que tu racontes
olivier
il serait il est
la preuve je le salue c'est tout dire
olivier
oui vielles
s'attaque aux pas beaucoup de peine à
six et il n'y a pas tout blanc de moi on
dirait presque ça te fait plaisir
plaisir tu sais que tu es vraiment un
cas sans aujourd'hui que c'est pas ça on
dit ça me fait plaisir que tu es sous
les yeux tombants beaucoup d'elle mais
oui quand on a fêté son nom pour la
deuxième fois j'ai eu l'impression que
tu pensais c'est pas possible ce serait
trop beau et bien que veux-tu il faut en
prendre ton parti c'est trop beau
remarque moi j'avais toujours une
impression tout ça finirait mal pas tout
ça m olivier c'est impossible c'est
encore tout à l'air tout à l'heure non
non non rien
il répond pas mais comment vont-ils qui
répondent à l'eau est ce que je pourrais
parler à monsieur olivier ta garde
à vous il n'est pas rentré mais comment
veux-tu quiero
non non rien merci
ils ne savent rien enfin tu trouves
normal doit tout ne sache rien j'ai une
vie ils savent pas ce que c'est on va
coûter drôle que personne ne les ai
prévenus ah ben oui là tu as raison
parce que tout même quand lucien est
remonté avec la glace et qui dit oui
enfin ne comprendront plus tard ça
m'étonnerait mai mais dis moi oui
comment était au courant toit de ce que
sa femme ignore et de ce que tout le
monde semble ignorer
voilà tu vas comprendre
c'est le hasard que veux-tu comme il le
disait olivier très justement c'est
toujours par hasard qu'on la compagnie
sont des semis me direz alors enfin pour
nous résumer il faut pas que tu m'en
veuille tout ça c'est très mal à ranger
j'ai vraiment pas eu de chance
lui non plus d'ailleurs
enfin en un mot comme ensemble
je les tuer
mais je n'étais que le bain mathieu ne
nous y trompons pas ce qui la tue ce
sont les vacheries qu'il a fait et et
celle qu'il allait faire
enfin à première vue si on ne pèse par
le courroux le compte c'est moi qui
l'ait tué n'y a pas d'erreur tu l'as
tuée mais comment des commandes au
bêtement c'est comme toujours il y avait
un presse papier qui traînait piouf je
vais taper sur la tête et il était lourd
ton presse papier et on se rend pas
quand tu sais rien ne paraît lourd dans
ces moments là en fait il n'a pas laissé
défendre mais j'avoue j'ai pas pensé
c'est inadmissible c'est encore le
téléphone
est ce que tu peux être obstiné
paul
auguste
c'était un air triste enfin
à l'eau est ce que je pourrais parler à
monsieur olivier tag and we à monsieur
olivier ty ar oui
oui c'est moi
ah bon
non merci
il avait dit qu'il rentrerait à cette
heure sans faute à qui
cette heure
il est presque neuf années est obligé de
la téléphonie 68 souligne
jeremy si pour toi aussi t'as pas taper
si fort que ça tu crois amputation
mandat fait longtemps n'ont pas
longtemps et était probablement déjà
ivre j'étais passé au tabac de la
guérison éponge qui me l'a déjà dit les
gens n'ont plus malheureux sweat shirt
était tellement ivre qu'adapter tapé à
côté 9e cette bande en tout cas les
blessures au crâne ou on meurt ou sait
rien du tout provient du tout rappelle
toi robillard quand il est entré la tête
la première dans un platane oui mais le
platane lui a pas taper dessus
c'est pas possible ça va comment comment
tu as et une chance pareille toi tu pars
ça je me demande comment comment est ce
arrivé oh non non non tu veux pas que je
te raconte
ces trompettes moi je commençais déjà à
tout oublier what i ve olivier
et bien moi je je je voulais lui
expliquer que mon salon n'était pas un
caveau de famille c'était rigolo non non
non non elle va alors voilà lier la
question du pas là il faisait une
chaleur
alors on va passer de pontiac oui on va
passer de plongée alors dit non il m'a
laissé moisir dans l'antichambre pendant
trois bons quarts d'heure
et comme il avait fermé les volets on y
voyait même pas pour lire alors j'ai
bavardé un peu avec le garçon de bureau
lucien il fera jamais rien ce garçon
large et en prime oui et alors l'olivier
a sonné il a envoyé lucien chercher de
la glace donc j'en ai profité mais
j'allais entrer
et puis je suis resté derrière la porte
parce que je n'ai entendu qui par les
toits
oui il téléphonait arago tiens tu sais
son copain l'arago pillant le le roi des
huns presse harry et ils lui disaient
les mains j'ai enfin obtenu un rendez
vous avec ma cousine ça y est c'est fait
elle est à moi oui en bois j'ai bien
compris vous voulez dire c'est une
question d'heures mon poste égal
entendre ce voyou se vanter des choses
pareilles il a dit ça je peux te répéter
chaque mot tu penses qu'un pion à lui
félicité entre salon au saas fee et leur
livia continuer selon tu vas me faire le
plaisir d'engager augus pour diriger un
orchestre et tu lui foutra huit mille
balles par mois alors l'autre a dû
gueuler au bout du fil parce qu'il l'a
stoppé par un c'est moi qui paye sans
répit au caire ses promesses surtout qu
il ajouté seulement pour ce prix là tu
vas lui faire voir du pays un
l'horizon ils ont discuté nous ce qui
valait mieux pour moi les casinos mythe
l'arabie séoudite
et ils n'ont pas pensé que je pourrais
de suivre
ainsi si mais qui paraît qu olivier
charge est ça un très bon alors comme
l'autre lui posait une question olivia
répandue
ah non
non ça va te vexer cet idiome ça va te
vexer non je ne crois pas
et bien alors il a répondu naturellement
isabelle me plaît naturellement je
l'adorent mais ce qui m'amuse surtout
c'est de rabattre le caquet de ma femme
elle me rase avec leurs amours leurs
belles amours leur grand amour 15 ans
d'amour ils vont voir ce que je vais en
laisse et de leur amour
il a raccroché
c'est la dernière chose qu'il ait dit tu
n'es tu as bien fait tu as bien fait bon
j'ai vu rouge tu entrais
alors qu'il était affalé dans un
fauteuil il avait sans son costume de
l'autre jour je ne voyais que ses bras
et le haut de son grade chouf
c'est là dessus que j'ai tapé pas
longtemps parce que j'ai entendu du
bruit je me suis enfui comme un voleur
enfin comme anas
mehdi tomber et j'y pense subitement
mais je suis un assassin n'y pense pas
mais tout ça parce qu'un type est venu
avec son ca l'argent qui n'est même pas
lu mon petit prix
oui pourquoi tu dis ça don quichotte
jeudi
j'ai tué quelqu'un ment ça a l'air d'une
blague qui a bien fait ça je te dis que
tu vas bien falloir que tu vas trop loin
dit la vérité il la sen sera mérité mais
non ils pensaient qu'à détruire notre
amour et ben justement c'était stupide
et n'a jamais été plus fort mais pas un
bon je te fais erreur c'est pas pour ça
pendant tout ce temps la fessée yen
devrait conforter mais je te jure sur ma
[ __ ] ou non je te fais erreur c'est la
police il faut répondre je suis sûr que
tu bois avec mon papier mais j'étais
bouleversé une décennie est foutu il
faut leur dire que tu est largement
enfouie lorsque je m'en fous l'hypothèse
image et de
sa
laisse et sinon
je te dégoûte pas
allô
allô oui je veux excuser moi je dormais
puis j'ai le sommeil très lourde
de la part de charlot
mais qu'est-ce que charlot vient faire
là dedans
bon je vous remercie mais vous pourriez
pas m'expliquer
il a raccroché c'est un mythe charlot
qui me téléphonent de sa part il paraît
qu'il faut que je foute le camp tout de
suite qu'est ce qu'il a dit exactement
ça foutait le camp tout de suite
lucien a mangé le morceau charlot vais
essayer d'arranger les choses mais
foutez le camp tout de suite sur le
corps attends attends pas ce que je
comprends donc c'est comme au charbon
pour essayer d'arranger les choses ça
oui tous sortis celui-là braff charlot
ce jour là quand on a besoin de lui
alors je foule commun comment donc ne
faut pas que tu t'en ailles mais
pourtant laisse moi réfléchir
j'ai une bien meilleure idée ah tiens
t'es plus bouleversé ainsi si
naturellement entre elles non non le
dirais pas écoute
malgré le conseil de charlot
faut pas que tu t'en ailles ça serait
avouer mais pourtant je pensais qu il n
ya qu un principe n'a plus jamais tu
crois raconter n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi mais n'avait jamais
qu'est ce qui va se passer
on va s'arrêter voilà tout mais entre
lâchera si tu m'écoutes
mais ce soir je vais coucher en prison
quelques heures je vais téléphoner à m
chernin téléphone puis parce que moi je
moi je fais une crise chez rim était
main tremble
je devrais peut-être préparer ma valise
je crois que tu as tout honte encore oh
tu crois qu'il me laisse mon pistons
c'est un sac tu penses que veux-tu je
sais pas à quoi il faut penser dans ces
cas-là manger j'ai pas l'habitude mais
il faut penser à ce que tu vas leur dire
la vérité ben non mon pauvre chéri est
ce que tu crois que le jury a titré
quelqu'un qui a fait ce que tu as fait
uniquement parce qu'il a eu peur d'être
trompé mais j'ai pas eu peur de
s'arrêter de police enfin quel est ce
que je trouve quelqu'un qui a cru qu'on
allait tenter de le tromper cgg 17 franc
je pouvais tout être vivant à dire qu'il
essayait de me les volumes écoute c'est
pas le moment de grâce aux roses je suis
pas à la hauteur
je te jure bien c'est la dernière fois
j'espère que tu entends ce que tu me dis
là n'ont même pas heureux
non mais dis donc toi toi tu es à la
hauteur
tu es prêt m'obéir oui tu discutera pas
n'ont pas confiance en moi complètement
absolument très bien
je vais te tirer de la roma pauvres peu
de changements
non m'appelle pas ma pauvre petit
pansement manches de suite il
m'a biquettes
prends moi dans tes bras
et écoute moi bien je t'écoute oui
tu n'es pas entrer dans le bureau bon
tu n'as pas entendu de téléphone tu t'es
vexé temps avait assez d'attendre et tu
es descendu tout de suite derrière
lucien c'est presque vrai la
téléphoniste at-elle vu passer
comment sais tu qui est le téléphoniste
ben tu imagines affaires comme celle
d'olivier dahan téléphonistes elle m'a
vu passer donc tu n'avais pas l'air
trois gars je crois pas un témoin de
plus tout s'arrange très bien alors
voilà
c'est moi la coupable
moi je lui résister il s'obstinait je
les frapper mais je ne veux comme tu
m'as promis de me dire mais jamais tu
entends jamais grâce subi je suis
stupide irréfléchie
une femme qui défend son honneur c'est
sacré pour la quitte toujours au bitume
époux ben oui ça tu peux pas savoir de
quoi je suis capable moi surtout
aujourd'hui on est faible mais je te
laisserai pas si non mais si
ton histoire tient pas debout mon pauvre
chou commencerait tu es entré dans le
bureau sans que lucien ni la
téléphoniste vois
tu penses que j'avais prévu cette
objection par la rue bojan
dans la rue bojan
bah oui à deux sorties comment elle
s'est tue tout le monde le sait ah je le
savais pas
olivier on a parlé si l'autre jour j'ai
pas entendu
c'était peut-être à la cuisine oui oui
peut-être bon bon alors admettons
admettons que tu sois entrée par la rue
bojan
villa bâton d'histoire et ya quand même
pas debout tu mens nuit tu sais mais
pourquoi mes empreintes digitales sur le
pape c'est juif ou pas juif ou non y'a
qu'un détail a changé
je lui résister tu es entré tu nous as
vu plantu la frappe et
a de l'imagination
oui un tas beaucoup d'imagination et
réfléchi un harry qui défend son honneur
c'est sacré on la quitte toujours
mais qu'est ce que tu fais il aurait
déchiré magique dont la nuitée voilà
mais cet idiot dhabi mais ces affaires
là je trouve pas moi mais d'autant plus
que ton histoire elle a été à toujours
pas tout mais tu m'ennuie pourquoi tu
était entrée par la rue bojan oui
pourquoi donc ne pas être vu
pourquoi ne voulais tu pas être vu
je ne sais pas si tu te caches est
tellement c'était probablement pas dans
l'intention de résister
probablement parler tu vois je suis
foutu
mais non
on n'a qu'à dire que j'étais sa
maîtresse
mais non monsieur je ne peux pas tout
dire et rien avait d'abord mais personne
ne le croirait ça ce sont des choses
qu'on croit toujours n'ont pas de toit
écoute tu parleras des fruits des fleurs
des cadeaux qui m'envoyait toral eu et
aura les concierges toral et poliakoff
comme témoin où ils mangent bien tout ça
parce que maintenant que je résiste plus
n'y a aucune raison
mais
comment comment et expliquera tuque se
soit déchiré parce que yen j'avais
résisté
dit dans
quelle invention qu'est l'environnement
dire j'avais des réserves
je m'en aperçoive mais je dois t'avouer
que c'est bien amusant d'essayer d'être
plus habile que à willis est amusant
terriblement mais alors mon chéri amis
soit parce qu'il ya encore des tas
d'explications à trouver oui lesquelles
par exemple puisque tu était entrée par
la rue bojan comment se fait-il que
lucien ne t'ai pas vu quand olivier l'a
sonné pour la glace
parce que je m'étais caché on ne pas
faire de peine à la cousine sophie
gachet où ça dans la pièce à côté
allemand c'est eu qu'à une pièce à côté
y'a pas pièce à côté si il ya une pièce
à côté
avec un divan
seulement comment tu sais tu
sois pas stupide tout le monde le sait
sans de hauteur
[Musique]
et olivier on a probablement discuter
ici l'autre jour on ans que j'étais à la
cuisine
mais pas du tout j'en ai parlé comme ça
au hasard comme de la téléphoniste oui
oui comme de la téléphoniste elle
n'aurait pas pu être un téléphoniste ah
si il fait plus qu'un vent tu es
tu de vie les téléphonistes sont des
femmes le plus souvent il y aurait pu y
avoir aussi une secrétaire et bien
curieux que tu es deviner qu olivier
n'en avait pas j'ai pas deviné est bien
plus curieux encore que tu te fâche pas
du temps je prends avec toi en ce moment
c'est pas dans mon habitude je me fâche
pas passe parce que je te comprends
c'est vrai ça c'est siri coïncidence
assez bizarre en effet quoi c'est
bizarre en fait chier c'est pas parce
que j'ai eu la malchance de tomber j'ai
eu la malchance de tomber juste et
justement en essayant de sauver la mise
oui oui aussi papa que c'est fini les
bêtises que j'ai tout compris il est
inutile de continuer à toucher qu'a
compris quoi je sais plus où la belle
a dégrisé un petit peu rudement tu as
compris quoi il ya qu un brin si dans la
vie
n'avouez jamais qu'est ce que tu veux
que je t'avoue raconter n'importe quoi
mais n'avouez jamais pas vu je te fait
peur hein un mari qui vend son honneur
c'est sacré on la quitte toujours
rassure toi un crime par jour pour moi
c'est un grand maximum
je suis tellement fatigué
au final
mais enfin at on idée de se met dans des
états pareils mais sans raison ça sans
aucune raison
c'est vrai tout tout ça est tellement
plus simple que tu crois
évidemment je t'ai pas dit toute la
vérité
évidemment mais étant donné la façon
dont tu prends les choses je la dois
maintenant et tout entière mais non
ainsi 1,6 aussi si c'est inutile c'est
idiot en fait je te la toile encore une
histoire d'amour pas comme les autres
qu'on va comme les qu'est ce que tu veux
dire s'il te plaît
le bonheur toujours le bonheur on s'en
fatigue oui tu souffres mais c'est fait
on peut on peut mourir de rire pendant
quinze ans mais on peut pas en vivre je
te laisserai pas faire du mal
stupidement
qu'embêtant à l'heure des repas de
n'être sûr que de la moutarde mais tu
sais que c'est pas vrai tu sais que
j'adore notre bohème et notre folie
écoute les soins laisse moi seulement
expliqué non non tu me dois rien tu n'as
pas de comptes à rendre et je te rendrai
l'achetant rentrée ça plaise ou non je
te rendrai
voilà
oui je suis allé chez olivier oui je
sais qu'il a une téléphoniste et pas de
secrétaire
j'étais allé lui demander comme toi
d'avoir un peu plus de tact dans ses
envois enfin tu peux pas me plaindre de
sa
réponse
et
puis
j'étais monté aussi pour la rue bojan
il n'a pas parlé de la seconde sortie
ici votre jour pendant que tu étais à la
cuisine
il m'a montré
ainsi que la pièce à côté qu'est ce que
tu as signé là je suis pas je sais pas
tu devrais après 15 ans tu devrais me
connaître lui en tout cas avec un
opinion moi ah oui oui oui parfaitement
lui ne me considère pas comme une fille
pour lui je suis quelque chose de rare
qu'il faut essayer de mérite et bien tu
vas pas attendu que j'ai téléphoné à
tout à l'heure le morceau de papier que
j'avais sorti de mon stack il y avait
inscrit le téléphone de sa carrière oui
sa garçonnière un nid d'amour une petite
merveille qui avait loué pour moi
paraît-il dans un poêle la rive gauche
où personne ne vous connaît il me disait
je ne demande pas d'y venir mais
seulement de me téléphoner et lorsque
vous verrez qu'un jour tu entends un
jour et un mois j'y vois toutes mes
soirées ajoute attendre alors vous
viendrez vous ne pourrez pas devoir dire
aux jurés
es
tu à téléphoner
je vais te faire de la peine
je téléphonais
si tu crois que c'est facile d'être une
femme
ça t'amuse est
malheureusement
pourquoi
mon chéri
depuis 15 ans nous nous parlons de nous
et lui
il m'a parlé de moi dès qu'on prend un
film à voir et c'est surtout
bon ça y est voilà jeté tous dit
oui parce que j'ai fait c'est mal c'est
très mal
mais enfin j'ai rien fait là dont tu
puisse souffrir dont tu téléphones à ce
[ __ ] tu permets à ce [ __ ] d'espérer
espère est il vraiment olivier et puis
que veux-tu à la pensée qu'il se
morfondait dans sa garçonnière à
m'attendre au lieu de courir prend les
boîtes avec les fit a dit le mot juste
moi ça m'amusait tu n'as jamais été
tentée de l'eau rejoint quand sasha mais
tu es fou
jamais
tu me crois
je te le jure sur ma vie
[Musique]
sur ma vie
et sur la mienne
tu jurerait aussi
dans la situation où tu es en ce moment
avec les dangers que tu cours
non
je t'assure que je pourrai le faire
j'espère que qu elle assuré
tu as probablement raison meilleur
assassin est cocu ce sera peut-être un
peu trop à la fois soit pas des mots
comme ça enfin écoute maintenant bah y'a
plus qu'à attendre ces messieurs avec ou
sans mon histoire s'entendent issoufou
sentons 17 ans u dont elle est trop
compliqué moi je m'embrouille aurait
pour arriver qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer dix mois qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire avec toi mais nous verrons bien tu
t'en fous pas de ce qu'ils vont faire de
toi dis moi mais bien sûr que non mais
qu'est ce tu veux
a plus qu'à attendre le nord attendait
donne moi une cigarette
la belle
mais qu'est ce qu'ils foutent
enfin radio isabelle n'embrasse pas si
tout à l'heure de vente des bruts et hu
devraient comprendre maintenant j'ai
besoin de tout mon courage et
je pense bien parce que c'est en quoi
tiens tiens voilà voilà 17 franc je te
demande pardon mais c'est tout ce qui me
reste est vraiment pauvre je pouvais pas
prévoir chez charlot s'occupera de toi
moi et donne ta main vite
pour notre avenir secondes de bonheur
je t'aimerai toujours
allumée je veux voir la gueule etc à la
justice notre justice
bonsoir mon cousin
donc bon soir
magazine
bonsoir
eh bien vous ne me faites pas entrer
vous ne me dites pas m'asseoir va
essayer vous
comment allez vous très bien merci mais
c'est que de fleurs ah oui c'est tuer
une admiratrice hamoir une folle à une
folle qui a beaucoup
bien vous ne vous asseyez pas
je ne vais pas m'en aller tout de suite
vous savez
j'adore ton
et vanilla
pour une surprise c'est une surprise
j'espère bientôt up à vous espérez que
non comment isabelle ne vous a donc pas
prévenu je vous appelle isabelle n'est
ce pas oui bien sûr le prévenu de quoi
mais comment et ne vous a pas dit que
nous et y ont rencontré cet après midi
pour certaines rues non je vais pas dit
non je comprends je comprends très bien
je l'avais pourtant prévenu que je
viendrai vous voir on n'est ce pas
isabelle oui oui pouvez lui mais aussi
auguste c'est votre four doux mettre
tellement sympa tu es moi et tout aussi
gentil sig et je ne sais pas si vous
avez raison
il ya longtemps vous avez vu olivier
vous oubliez que c'est mon arrivée oui
un drôle de marie je le reconnais mais
enfin c'est mon avis tout de même je ne
reste jamais très longtemps voire non je
crois qu augusta veut savoir si si vous
avez vu olivier ce soir donc à
auguste veut sans doute savoir si
olivier vous a parlé de la visite qu'il
lui a fait
non mais il m'en parlera sûrement quand
j'aime mais vous n'avez pas
vous avez là de le regretter
il m'a téléphoné chez mon coiffeur pour
ta gueule
quoi vous êtes drôles vers 6h et à
quelle heure là tu veux toi ah ouais
malheureusement c'est pourquoi
malheureusement
[Musique]
c'était un curieux coup téléphone
mais bon on vous à part à téléphoner
depuis on ne vous a rien dit qui
voulez-vous goûter les vins que voulez
vous qu'on dise vous vous ne deviez pas
dîné avec olivier non non non nous
allons nous retrouver chez des amis vers
11 heures il devait dîner dans sa
garçonnière
we7 garçonnière que je paie il faut vous
dire que notre cher olivier est en ce
moment d'une méchanceté et imaginables a
vraiment il est d'une méchant et ben oui
ça me fait du bien parce que vous dites
là prête pas attention
un peu plus ce soir qui pourrait lui
reprocher alors vraiment il est d'une
méchanceté
inimaginable il n'y a que moi qui
pourrait le punir malheureusement je
n'en ai pas la force et ce que parce que
je pourrai voir quelque chose c'est vous
dire que sans moi il ne pouvait plus
rien contre personne
comme ça battons nous pour vous
auguste oui je voudrais que vous vous en
allez mon petit august
pourquoi voulez vous que mon mari s'en
aille j'ai à vous parler isabelle à moi
vous savez quoi ma foi non c'est la
suite de notre conversation cet après
midi je ne vois pas un remarquer que je
peux très bien tout raconté aux d'hulst
qu'en pensez vous c'est à dire vous êtes
de mon avis n'est ce pas on abîmerait
tout en lui racontant
abîmé quoi
cette histoire de femme je ne pouvais
pas vraiment notre cousine a raison je
crois qu'il vaut mieux que tu en as you
used
as non non non pas là
rappelez vous on entend tout nous est
meilleur
vous voulez que je descends s'il
faudra dire deux fois mais sûrement dans
cinq minutes oui
et moi qui vous aident mirettes
bon je ne vous juge pas la passion
d'olivier vous et amusez vous êtes cru
plus forte que lui
a il est très fort
très fort
il avait prévu le moment exact de votre
défaillance il m'avait demandé où serez
vous entre 6 et 7 j'aurais peut-être
quelque chose à vous dire il nous a
quittés vers 6h jeu n'est ce pas
à 6h25 il me téléphonait chez mon
coiffeur pour m'apprendre la bonne
nouvelle
il paraît que je l'avais agacé avec
votre amour
1 mais aussi tout ça est arrivé par ma
faute c'est moi qui ai insisté pour
venir à ce déjeuner serait tellement
entendu parler de votre guité de votre
courage devant l'un fortune
vous avez tout de même résisté trois
semaines
olivier ne devait pas venir écouter me
parlez pas tout le temps de lui nous ne
sommes pas dans une situation qui nous
permet d'avoir beaucoup de tact encore
moins elle vous croyez je sais
c'est à cause de vous qu'il n'est pas
sorti pendant ces trois semaines pour
attendre vos coups de téléphone vous
m'écoutez oui je vous écoute c'est la
première fois qu'il s'impose une coque
débrayent
ils devaient tenir joliment à vous je ne
crois pas non non pas de modestie entre
nous vous lui plaisait énormément foule
c'est ici il est même possible que vous
lui plaisier encore
ici surtout après les rôles mort que
vous avez eue
olivier m'a dit que vous songiez à
vous penserez
nos larmes ont sûrement été le meilleur
moment de sa journée
et voulez mais
je ne pense pas que cela vous regarde
pas
sophie
je vous appelle sa fille n'est ce pas
c'est un nom plus simple je n'arrive pas
à croire que vous soyez venu seulement
pour m'insulter j'aurais très bien pu
c'est dans mon caractère j'ai même pensé
alors
j'ai relancé et pourquoi
parce que vos larmes ont été aussi le
meilleur moment de ma journée à moi
je me suis dit si elle sanglote rien
n'est perdu
je connais olivier ces 20 jours sans
sortir ce petit attendrissement survola
mans il n'a pas de remords mais s'ils se
mettaient avoir des regrets
je ne veux pas de ça
acceptez-vous de quitter paris tout de
suite
nous ne pouvons pas partir qu'est ce qui
pourrait vous en empêcher on nous
laissera pas partir on
olivier
naturellement non mais qui alors je ne
peux pas vous le dire attention isabelle
en pleurant vous avez été très poli je
vous en remercie mais maintenant les
simagrées ne suffisent plus
si vous avez eu une heure de folie fois
comme vous dites 12 autres et bien
prouvé le parti tout de suite
je le voudrais je ne pourrais pas
j'avancerais les choses à celle là
et vous n'avez pas de raison à me donner
à vous non
olivier un mois
si vous vous incruster je vais devenir
très déplaisante et je suis capable de
l'être aussi pour la dernière fois
acceptez vous de quitter paris non
non non c'est bon maintenant je ne peux
plus le détester c'est drôle
moi aussi je ne l'avais pas aimer
aimer
je n'aurais pas pu supporter cinq
minutes ça devrait vous rassurer
seulement parce que je laime je suis
prête à tout pour le garder absolument à
tous
ma survie dans le midi elle vous donnera
les moyens d'ouvrir là bas la plupart de
vos rêves je ne peux rien accepté de
vous et vous en effet si votre mari
déguste encore moins que moi oui
supposer qu'un jour il après rien à
craindre
vous ne vous êtes pas demandé pourquoi
j'avais abordé cette histoire du
faubourg-saint-honoré à 6 eh bien ma
chère
nous ne nous sommes pas quittés cet
après midi je vous ai emmené prendre le
thé est traîné schéma couturière j'ai
des témoins
d'ailleurs pourquoi irais-je imaginé ça
ne me remerciez pas je travaille pour
moi aussi
si auguste ne sait rien tout le plaisir
d'olivier sera gâchis ah non non non non
non il ne faut pas qu'on croie que j'ai
passé l'après midi avec vous pourquoi ah
non il faut qu'il soit bien établi que
je suis allé en campagne première vous
tenez à ce qu'on sache que je suis
trompé mais d'ailleurs quelqu'un m'a vu
là-bas quelqu'un le dira mais qui qui
voulait boxer intéressés s'il le dit pas
moi je le dirai vous en êtes si fine
mais il faudra que je le dis
non non je ne comprends pas dit autre
chose est sûre que vous voulez protéger
quelqu'un c'est visible et ce quelqu'un
doit être gosses d'étape sur pourquoi
avez vous eu l'air terrifié tous les
deux quand je suis entré lui tous les
deux vous se comprend mais lui mais nous
n'avions pas que je ne peux pas accepter
la proposition que je vous ai fait et
pourquoi lui surtout pourquoi
m'avez-vous demandé dix fois ci j'avais
vu olivier ce soir
ils se sont battus à cause de vous ils
se sont battus n'est ce pas angus
c'était fouilles il a eu un mouvement de
jalousie n'a pas osé ne lui a pas fait
de mal olivier n'est pas en danger
olivier olivier
olivia l'ofii
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la caisse qu'elle te
voulez oui oui oui elle nous après de
l'argent pour ouvrir un bar dans le midi
moi j'ai sûrement eu un mot malheureux
mais pourquoi est elle dans cette école
comment aurait-on pu croire qu'elle
l'aimé à ce point là j'avoue les folles
de lui malheureusement il est capable de
tuer paul du passeur du c'est qu'elle en
est capable
c'était un massacre
on écoute on va pas encore se dire adieu
on finirait par avoir l'air idiot
à
mais là
en voilà une histoire
comme
toi aussi comment moi aussi mais l'homme
aux presse papier chez moi
il
n'ya pas dire mais moi
je suis plus un assassin on parle
c'est bien toi qui as tous reçus à
chatou
j'ai pas taper sur quelqu'un d'autre non
non il y en a eu pour moi
ça alors on peut dire que tu es un ami
on peut médecine oh non non non merci
mme augustine la peine que j'ai le crom
sol il pas de cervelle à yann de l'os
vous savez était une canne pareil je
l'aurais car ce cas c'est d'ailleurs le
presse papier je les cabosses cabossée
mais non je blague à une blague quand je
les adore cet homme là maintenant tu
pourrais peut-être m'expliquer pourquoi
le presse-papier belge avait que ça sous
la main pas du tout l'encrier pouvait
très bien faire la faire qu'il était
beaucoup moins de voirie j'ai pas
réfléchi tu aurais dû en tout cas tu
vois moi chérie les blessures au crâne
où on en est où c'est rien dit rien du
tout je dirais c'est pas trop grave
bref un bon rempart programme ne suis
quand même pas très solide sur mes
jambes
tu vas te casser la gueule
dans mon état ça soit vraiment du luxe
tu m'avais pas trop euh non je sais bien
que c'est pas de ta faute si tu
m'assassiner aussi tu n'avais pas besoin
de taper si fort et si le père est
pourtant sommet ça faisait banques dans
ma tête a bien dit que ça faisait
banques afin que je sois francs sur le
moment je tourne et voulu je vous
comprends j'ai vraiment failli mourir
sans savoir pourquoi ben oui surtout
quand je t'ai reconnu je vous disais
mail est idiot qu'est ce qu'il a fait
comme ça
je te prenais pour olivier mois - tu as
pu me prendre pour olivier mais oui d'où
j'étais moi je voyais coq ton crâne
et ton costume au nom de gueule costume
c'est ça j'avais vu le sien d'autres
jours en descendant l'escalier j'ai
voulu faire faire le même avec un joli
petit gilet une fière idée du la halle
de table qu'il m'avait déjà engueuler
avant que tu m'as sommes oui monsieur
n'aime pas qu'on le copie allons bon bon
alors j'admets que tu aies pu être
trompés par le costume mais que diable
je suis quand même plus petit lui ah ben
tu étais assis il me semble pourtant que
même massue a battu été votée en beauté
vous l'entendiez noble
oui j'étais un petit peu
avant pendant et après on vous explique
tout en plus que tu été votée à côté du
téléphone alors qu'olivier venaient
précisément de téléphoner et au fait
mais oui tu es tu passé olivier dans la
pièce à côté si vite oui on l'appelait
repart quand j'avais vraiment imaginer
qu'il y avait eu confusion seulement
c'était trop tard
j'étais déjà à la salpêtrière mais
qu'est ce qui vous y amener le garçon
bureau lucien dit on est fragile
derrière ce garçon là jamais
et olivier je faisais un olivier était
parfait comme d'habitude il se tordait
j'entends son riz alors tu comprends
qu'on les atteint moins sûrs accommoder
j'ai essayé d'en faire voir que je
m'étais cogner mais ça n'a pas pris faut
pas demander l'impossible d'autant plus
qu'ils étaient formels si j'avais rendu
l'homme comme on dit vulgairement et
bien qu'il était bon pour la prison à
purger laure c'est pour ça que je te
conseille à de [ __ ] le camp alors
quand vous disiez que vous alliez
essayer d'arranger les choses ça
signifie que j'allais essayer de ne pas
me laisser glisser de tenir bon avant eh
bien je les tenais tu vois ça crache
arnould et en plus de tous les ans
vêtements fallait encore que je me fasse
du souci pour toi tu l'as d'or cet
homme-là éviter la pole c'est à toi que
j'avais pensé pour pour t'occuper
d'isabelle en cas de malheur ou que ce
genre à me vendre autour comme un charme
je voudrais vous prouver notre
recommande
avec avec 17 france ce sera pas facile
comment tu n'as que 17 points bêtement
je disais pas ça pour ça après ce que tu
as déjà fait pour moi ça n'a aucun
rapport au sérieux sa triste que vous
souffrez beaucoup de la tête non il
paraît même que je n'aurais jamais pu
migraine dis moi merci merci on le là
vous avez ski très gentil lokua qui on
allait tous les trois l'angine bois
auquel polluer mais c'est moi qui régale
vient d'échapper à la catastrophe entre
a plus jamais aussi guen profitons-en je
vais prendre mon chalet jaoui voilà j'ai
décidé en pour le futur de maximum pour
un meurtrier je te trouve un peu détendu
à petit mais toi ma place un moment que
ça sert jamais assez le même pas la
peine d
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui fais à
des vidéos ont été un cochon moi
oui tu as été assez gentil au moment du
presse papier elle me semble et même
après
mais avant avant la wii le coup de
téléphone d'olivier à son copain ragots
pian tu l'avais entendu toi aussi non
non je m'excuse ainsi toi mon meilleur
ami tu entendu sans protester olivier
dirar hagopian dit dans mon vieux notre
pari à propos de ma cousine ça y est
c'est fait elle est à moi tu peut
allonger t8000 forme plus je pensais à
mon garage tu l'as laissé dire leur
amour ils vont voir ce que je vais en
laisse et de leur amour mais je savais
bien qu'il se vantait qui ne s'occupait
pas du tout deezer a vraiment mais pas
du tout et j'avais de bonnes raisons
pour le savoir ah oui oui à première
chose qui m'avait annoncé en entend
c'était à mon vieux vous avez de l'aven
vous avez vous un homme admirable mot
disposer il y avait une carte qui me
faisait drogué de pippa joue depuis 20
jours sans sortir le soir à attendre ses
coups de téléphone elle est enfin venu
c'était prévisible vous pouvez croire
que j'en ai profité quand tu vois bien
que de ce cube par isabelle
je regrette d'avoir raté
qu'est ce que tu dis
enfin l'idiote ce n'était tout de même
pas vous
tellement pardon je n'ai jamais pu
imaginer pas une seconde
je croyais tellement
honnête
vous m'excuserez
moi aussi je me croyais au net les mois
pour un b si j'avais bien pensé à me
tuer n'aurait jamais rien su
j'espère être encore heureuse avec toi
j'avais pensé que ça s'arrangerait
peut-être
ça s'est pas arrangé
ça s'arrange jamais non
tu veux que je m'en aille tout de suite
sans mal et où tu sens à l'aise c'est
tout ce qu'elle s'obstine ça vaudra
peut-être que demain tu seras plus qu'un
syndic en toi ce concept docteur un
après ce que tu as fait ici mais
monsieur s'en fout mais s'est trouvé
très bien qu'elle s'en aille bien ne
s'ennuiera pas tu m'intéresses on n'ira
pas je te jure 400 n'ya pas simple alors
on brise la vidéo type le plus audible
que je m'arrête tout de suite pourquoi
tu fais ça
pour quoi
j'ai pas d' excuses
gens cherchent pas c'est trop difficile
parce que j'ai jamais cessé de t'aimer
la bonne blague si si j'en ai une
seulement elle est tellement lamentables
malheureusement c'est la seule j'en ai
pas d'autre alors que la donne pour ce
qu'elle vaut
voilà
pendant une heure il m'a empêché de
penser à toi pendant quinze ans je ne
suis pas resté une seconde sans penser à
toi
il m'a suffi de 7 heures c'est pire que
tout ce que tu dis là mais j'ai été
punie va soit tranquille j'ai su le pire
j'ai su qu'il ne me voulaient que contre
toi que pour pouvoir te le dire
c'est dieu / / moisé
pct andine
qui m'avait juré que
c'était pas vrai jurai sur tel coup tu
sais ma vie je risquais l'injure et
non la seule chose qu'on aurait pu le
sauver
c'est que tu n'es jamais rien su
parce que
parce que je pourrais vraiment aimé
je rappelle ce que tu disais l'autre
jour
nous sommes très bien dans les
embêtements il faudrait nous voir dans
le malheur
tu nous vois dans le malheur
de pabos
et les jolies notre amour le tient sur
le toit parce qu'on fait un mois qu'on a
essayé du tout chez vous j'ai tout de
même fait quelque chose j'ai tout de
même à sauver quelqu'un weemer freeware
pas celui qu'il fallait c'est entendre
cust ont de la femme convient de trouver
les mots qu'on mérite il faut croire que
je méritais un salon tu n'es qu'un sale
ou regarde là ces dames sont des fidèles
dont elles sont curieuses elles veulent
se rendre compte eh ben tu t'es rendu
compte est content on dit que je
n'entende plus c'est vrai il a du charme
à olivier imbéciles 20
mon cher imbéciles
donc je vais m'en aller
au n'importe où ça m'est bien égal
c'est bien fini
n'est ce pas
ça va être long la vie
sans bus
et moi qu'est ce que je vais faire sans
elle
mais au fond mais tout ça mais mais
c'est ta faute
voilà elle est bien bonne mais s'il ya
une brute qui si ce n'est pas à il ne
parle pas du bonhomme quitte valence est
des grands coups de presse papier
celui-là croyait bien faire donc je
parle de celui qui ose parler comme tu
pas une femme désespérée tu me trouves
pas à ces valeureux car l'auto qui va te
casser la gueule
mais tu ta n'ont pas regardé se
détestent tellement la pauvre elle a une
telle honte d'elle même écoute moi tu
feras ce que tu voudras mais moi je ne
te pardonnerai jamais si tu fais du mal
à cette femme là il faut pas la laisser
comme ça il faut pas la laisser partir
écoutez c'est à dire proche normaux moi
je pouvais pas laisser passer ça sans
rien à dire j'ai pas été tellement
méchant
petit
j'ai pas tellement mes choux au four du
négoce à l'égoïsme mais oui bien sûr je
suis un égoïste
est ce que tu veux sommes parfaits pour
le malheur et les mois
c'était notre anniversaire jeudi
nous n'aurons plus jamais d'anniversaire
charlot oui j'avais
m'abandonnerait pas vous viendrez me
voir moi puisque je vous ai fait m'avait
rien fait
vous avez cru en moi comme auguste
comme braquo pions car en fait il avait
parié sur moi fera que je lui fasse des
excuses en ont tous
malgaches mais que veux-tu
5000 jour 5000 me rappelent c'était trop
dieu s'est fatigué mais pourquoi
il était trop jolie notre amour
je me suis glissé dedans comme dans un
lit
et je me suis endormi voilà
tu me chasses pas
dit
tu me détestes pas tout à fait
si seulement on pouvait être malheureux
antho en noir il n'est pas question de
ça alors alors pas question une seconde
où on est heureux ensemble on n'est pas
ensemble du tout voilà tu as le malheur
membres et sympathique
bon allez allez vas te coucher
[Musique]
mais
mais tu te lâchera pas pour souffrir
ça
ça me regarde d'ailleurs souffrir c'est
offrir de quoi du du ridicule de ce que
comment dire les autres envers les
autres je veux dire
s'offrir au fond de toi
charlot oui mon vieux
croire c'est drôle j'ai déjà presque
plus mal lotis que j'ai eu peur
si si la belle sait mais des jeux je
pourrais peut-être me consoler et si tu
te console tu pourrais lui pardonner je
suis tellement égoïste qui pourrait me
pardonner comme ça comme ça et j'ai même
la prétention que nous soyons heureux
encore
and on
and on toi tu n'as pas le droit de le
décourager
n'oublie pas que tu dois m'aider ce sera
difficile - tu ne crois suis même
capable d'oublier je te le dis je suis
tellement égoïste qui d'ailleurs tu me
connais tu oublieras je pourrais pas te
pardonner si je savais pas que
j'oublierai
le nom ne garde pas ses terres coupable
il faut oublier
toi aussi
j'essaierai
reste la plus forte de nous deux
tu es sûr de mon amour
mais naturellement
tu n'as pas peur que je recommence non
pas toi
tu es une femme c'est entendu mais tu es
aussi un monsieur c'est toujours ce
qu'on dit avec son pouce
bien chéri
comme tu es fort
pas tellement
mais c'est ce que je veux
tu m'embrasses pas
tout à l'heure
à tête reposée
je nous prépare une petite
county voudra
il sait mieux que moi
bravant les enfants alors je me sens
tout acheter qu'elle vient enfin on se
marre et pour fêter tout ça des fleurs
merci
on en a décidément je vous aime bien
tous les deux
il faut croire que tout est vraiment
devenu normal d'y penser ça si oui je
crève de faim
on sortira tout ça c'est ma peau
je n'aime pas les inviter à déjeuner
quelle idée de me traîner jusqu ici un
peu de tact mon cher il faut tourner à
les rassurer qu'ils sachent que vous
n'êtes pas non moi je trouve ça dommage
tout de même quel [ __ ] cet olivier
ihl le sa discipline si tu trouves pas
c'est un salon ça recommence la seule
chose qui me console un peu de ne pas
l'avoir tué un peu seulement c'est le
soulagement qui a dû avoir sa femme la
seule fois que vous n'ayez jamais donné
un gratte on tu m'avais dit comparer
plus de lui on sait la dernière fois là
il n'existe plus supprimant les c'est
une manif la première chose que je vais
faire demain matin c'est fou de ces
fleurs la poubelle oui moi c'est dommage
je vis figuraient ses fruits à tous les
états à raison du tarissement des
avalats de birmanie et tu prends plaisir
de lui renvoyer tout ce cadeau j'en ai
le placement
déjà cet égard
l'accueil qu'ils feraient s'ils savaient
qu'il n'a rien pu contre nous
assez
allons nous en maintenant nous leur
avons fait assez de mal
les voilà repartis pour 15
alors santé
isabelle
vidon gens qui pensent tout à coup il
faudra rien dire à ta mère amélie tu
fonces à lui fait trop de peine je n'ai
jamais autant aimé
nous avons eu la joie de jouer ce soir
devant vous le moulin de la galette de
marcel achard
[Musique]
dans un décor de roger hart
les costumes de donald cardwell
et une mise en scène de max fournel
notre moulin à tourner grâce à brigitte
chamarande
et dire azimi
françois dalle ou
gisèle tourret
jean l'ice
bernard dhéran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]